you know what I have been obsessed
though while I've been away I've still
been playing games obviously but I've
been obsessed with altar path traveller
it's so good
and I just likes it you know in bed you
just play it or like Alan the Sun when
it's sunny and play it it's such a good
game I'm so into it just like so many
different bill stories and of course my
favorite is um okay I'm really bad with
names I can't remember their names but
you the one who's like practically a
Pokemon master
and she like captures captures like
she's my favorite she's she's the best
this one
I want to start again dammit I have to
continue and I'm just like stops in the
beginning of this one
[Music]
we cite your game from this chapter I
guess this is all we can do just go back
to like an earlier said oh wow we didn't
get that far in anyways
yes please
we'll save over this one row seat I've
already played Captain stirrup but on my
playstation 4 stupid me playing on other
stuff camera the paper I can what am I
talking about PS 5 is already about to
be a thing
who are the hustles
once upon a time in a wild aisle where
i'll well aware to wolf brothers living
in their home their with their papua
they all lived happily together but one
day i just took that dan away forever oh
this is the beginning now the brothers
were lonely and they had to find a new
home they started a journey through the
great big forest wolf brothers wandered
for days nights learning how to live on
their own for the first time
they slept in the backwoods my creepy
creatures barely Ayden's
they eventually found a peaceful orchard
and were able to eat in peace but they
didn't know
I'll just try to tie them up for the
wolf brothers managed to escape with the
help of a friendly bear he showed them
how to survive and help them to find a
warm camp for the night
that's when the big brother discovered
that the little one was not an ordinary
wolf but a super
Dilawar that's how they found themselves
even further headed to the faraway land
there Bob
with you
find peace I want the birth of Mexico
Luther they have no powers
in about Lass's characters
we did for you hey Rafa
I asked 69 bizzle
Oh doggy
- this doggy
he's a good boy
try with it
that one's too easy
what don't brag it was too heavy for you
a few days ago
[Music]
let's try to lift something else not too
heavy though I'm a little tired
okay I am in control
can you tell we're not we're not doing
mushroom I I'd said this last time I'm
not gonna make him pick up the dog
welcome to animal cruelty one please
don't kill your teacher how about trying
out that rock over there just one more
time we already tried yesterday and the
day before it's too far I can't reach it
just one more time at the fullest guys I
can feel it
how about that morning what'd you do
with the small rocks but not the big
ones you can do this trust me just relax
focus
I'll try do or do not there is no try
[Music]
whoo holy [ __ ] like a boss you're
getting good at you see that mushroom
that was the biggest rock ever mushroom
mushroom sorry
[Music]
Wow oh yeah his sketches were to make
sure the sketch
wait oh no buses will be going
to recite Shakespeare in quotations I
don't know why I've got I'm cold
let's get done with this practice
session how about those cans can you buy
them all together without dropping any
sure look that's awesome dude
you're getting way better at this come
on dude that's just the start let's try
something else
you're like co-chairing power a snowball
fight not yet
this is a new exercise young apprentice
see if you can stop this in the air cool
okay well you better not hit me like
that time you gave me a bruise serious
you won't let me right try it I'm not
gonna hurt you good boy
oh that's sucked ready
I don't want to hit him I don't want to
give him a bird yes look look what I can
do Shawn I knew that you could have
taught you well do you hear a master
student Hey Ya muffin you're not getting
better I told you I'm fine just a little
beat well you need to rest now superhero
Oh yep cons I know you don't want to
miss this can we go back now yeah let's
just fill up the canteens before we head
back Joey has been going on for days
Daniel I really don't like that I told
you I'm fine he's just been outside for
a while thanks Danny
I need to catch some of your strings I'm
sorry I've been missing them I keep
seeing that you've done them I'm like I
want to see you draw so bad okay what
are we doing here
here we go
the helitanker is over the wildfire zone
get ready for water it's stretching
Ranger Diaz nice work Daniel glad to see
your training sessions are paying off
thanks to you so glad I don't have to
touch that water
it's too [ __ ] cold whoops sorry
yeah dude what's your neck seriously
okay what what did you climb sure what
did he find
oh come on not again hey it's been a
while since we last saw our habit who
lives in there yeah I hope it wasn't
eaten by a bear oh look Daniel I think I
saw that rabbit from the other day he's
trying to get home oh I want to see the
bunny my hand Hey oh dude your face you
suck come on Daniel I was just kidding
around
Oh Sean a family that lived here dead
maybe to another state but they left all
their stuff behind I don't know man
maybe they live in Florida and only come
here every 10 years maybe they got tired
of these woods I kind of like it here
it's way cooler than that crappy town
where the shelter was I just I miss my
friends had my room sometimes yeah me
too
Oh almost forgot to check our traps
today
[Music]
finding that house was a miracle but I'm
afraid we can't stay here much longer
sorry guys we don't take anymore guests
well they're wolves this accurate what
kind of dog were you sandy a cool stray
mutt like our little mushroom
toys oh he's drunk yep no me tonight
Daniel helps me slice wood by holding
the logs with his power pretty useful
too bad this wood is rotting plate hub
gi-du be stuck in our to keep the house
warm
[ __ ] miracle we found this place
three weeks ago you okay where is he
hello
Danielle's getting cold come on let's
get inside didn't warming up we had to
use candles give to break in
oh don't worry we'll make a fire we're
pros now dude
that cuff doesn't sound too good nah I'm
okay
just cold you kicked ass today
level up I did that was so cool
it's getting easier every day
why don't up a word this is a Honda more
like uh-oh it's time to go or the rules
I told you about showing off
I was just whatever dude you're the
rules let's find out what's the first
one
[Music]
hide your power if you spend one plate
in a diner what happens people yeah and
when people freak what do they do they
call the tops exactly the second rule is
don't uh never talk about it
Wow nice Daniel cuz that's usually the
hardest rule for you shut up
and the final rule I know
come on um you can do it okay um avoid
danger run from danger this is the most
important one you know why uh I don't
know I mean with my power I can help us
mmm like yeah it's dangerous but also
maybe as a lovely as a total blast or
sort hello I know that if there's any
other way of helping do that first
maybe if I hey sketcher I've used it
before dad might still be here
that was out of it you didn't even know
that [ __ ] was out of your control but
look what happened to the policeman
maybe this power is a curse or something
hey we have no clue would happen and
it's not your fault
don't worry mushroom I'm okay
good puppy boy she must be hungry
what about you I'm always hungry and
let's grab out I'll make us some dinner
yeah before she eats us
nom-nom-nom so how is life estranged so
far it's good although I haven't played
it in a long time but the first episode
was really good I hate it when I hear
Daniel crying at night I don't think it
will ever be like the last one though
because I could relate to the last one
like a lot and I can't believe - this
one at all but three it's still really
interesting Wow cuz I can't believe but
it's giving me like new insight into
into kind of big topics I guess this is
more yeah it's more away from the
reality than most people know
because I think that the last life is
strange was all based around kind of a
lot of problems that people have growing
up and like mental health and stuff
which a lot of people go through but
this is a lot more specific I guess but
it's so good
wait is mushroom a girl Nikki she's a
good boy [ __ ] what should I put my
lighter
we'll find it done why
hey miss Mimi show cute that is ready
for today's training puppy say it shroom
sit seriously girl oh she's good
mushroom sick girl Giga are you kidding
me
you just don't know how to talk to her
I'll remember this traitor coming thank
God kids used to spend vacations here
Daniel would have been mad without these
it's you're so far away now
is it lighter and we scored with these
clothes +5 street cred the guy who came
here sure had time to Cail
no worries thanks for coming Danny Olson
owns Arctic
enjoy your dinner hey shroom you thirsty
officer root are you being serious about
Turrentine cuz that's disgusting
and you can leave lucia got slash feels
weird to be living in their own
poor guy I guess I have to grow up
anyway right yeah so that's me wait I
think I read um have you heard about
Wendy's yes why did you ask me that
Wiggy
I mean that's the rarest II don't know
fresh I had more tobacco to pass food
what do you mean do you mean like
alcohol or like marijuana there was a
little bit left when we came pretty
disgusting but help staying warm feels
almost good to be cut off from
everything so can't find it so where is
it yep no more indoor training sessions
Oh
later protip always boil the water
unless you want Daniel spraying nasty
things on both ends
can any of that help hello hotel room
soap once you got used to squatting yeah
that's not so bad well cause they can't
use the toilet
hey I put some clean water in the
bathroom so you can wash a little
no more peeing at night for Daniel got
so scared I'm lucky he didn't blow up
the house outside I think this bag this
thing as strong as a rock no wait no so
the light is not in here
got a loved one hit wonders
yeah there's a lighter time to get warm
yeah Daniel doesn't need to see this hmm
chemotherapy wait wha
is that the person that lived there
before or is that their dad because it's
the president lived there before so he
had cancer
no excuse not to been free oh yeah he
definitely cared for us what a piece of
[ __ ] oh is this about police
investigating a store in Beijing by two
CS of Runaways believed to be
responsible for the deaths of Seattle
police officer in October
thanks Tom Platt owner of a gas station
of highway 5 and a pillar of the
community said he confirms it confronted
the two brothers Sean and Daniel Diaz
after you recognize him then at his
store Stamford Hill with the police the
brothers escaped in the woods
they looked lost in a bed rest I was
only trying to help them as a father and
a citizen Yeah right
oh wait there was another page oh yeah
how can I feel bad for him
Ashley Matthews sister of officer
Kinberg Matthews killed in a mysterious
and controversial Seattle incident that
left two dead has released a statement
regarding the threats she received an
online critics of the officer
my brother was a kind man he was in the
force for only six months and should
have shouldn't have been left alone that
day my heart is with the Diaz family and
all the victims of that terrible
accident
including us the police department needs
better fundings and no officer goes on
patrol alone if their partner was sick
or unavailable kindred offered his life
to helping others especially children in
at-risk homes and he always volunteers
his time for charity
it's easy for people to judge and attack
behind a keyboard but just as we mourn
for others we mourn the loss of a brave
public servant so that's the police
officer that killed our dad well there
lad in the first episode and then
obviously Daniel kind of went and yeah
killed everyone well two people it was
the the guy inside the fight and the
police officer wonder were Proteus now
oh yeah
no internet
dead for a week but at least we got some
news I'm used to ink so this will
different they have time to learn now
okay
all right Daniel let's get you can't
believe how much Daniels powers have
improved over the last week's
here we go
hold on mushroom we're gonna build a
fight
dang I am starving guess it's time to
start cooking what do we have to eat so
bad I can't make a pizza fly to us he
looks so serious on this picture still
can't believe he's gone
I miss him so much it hurts Shawn I know
ordained Ian thanks for popping in to
told me to think about have a good day I
do it too okay Shawn why are you
apologizing Nicky how'd you do in Russia
you're the best puppy in the world
I'm just glad you found you may wonder
how far it can go here's the food mmm
tough choice so will this a better talk
to Daniel after dinner hey what are you
cooking
oh I'm sorry here's your menu choices
ravioli or ravioli okay okay never I'm
so tired of eating the same [ __ ] I just
want one slice of pizza
so how we gonna turn samavyapti though a
dude you'll be moving cars around in no
time if you keep improving like that
well that'd be a bad idea but you sure
are getting good at this
I wonder if there's anyone else like me
mmm
I think we'd know it by now
but a [ __ ] is back
you stole mushrooms ravioli yesterday
yeah
next time we'll call the forest cops you
whiskered thug
give it Suzy how are we gonna kick this
ravioli oh my it's so tired of eating
the same [ __ ] I just want one slice of
pizza
this room is [ __ ] cold so you put
everything we didn't need in it and keep
it closed
hmm that's good could do a super cool
manga about Daniel where is it there you
go
it's off now
Daniel loves his brand-new tablet
man I miss listening to music so [ __ ]
much no way I'm touching that oh my god
that's terrifying
okay but still how do I cook this
ravioli cook it on the stove we really
lucked out stumbling into this house
need to cook the ravioli kind of weird
to use stranger stuff everyday but not
like we have a choice
these were all I found when I hit the
town last week
I wish I helped dad more with the house
drawers back then tobacco to be honest
what the hell am i doing I don't know as
bad as I said would be we never found
the key to this door
I guess using a sliding door is cool
Tanny only states psychic crap huh
that's warming up feels so good I wish
we had a big fireplace like in Seattle
of course I remember you always got sick
on s'mores and ruined the toilet yeah I
know
you okay nobody's sick for more than a
week
hey they have well in tobacco they have
mush sure Nikki but like a really cute
mushroom people will not see the
gameplay because it's full of spoilers
but it's very old so I think people who
don't care or have already played will
be fine you don't have to do okay got it
this whole gameplay mechanic still feels
kind of weird like you hold down the
left mouse button and then just kind of
move your mouse random directions booked
enough times you draw now I get the
focus again but like the whole drawing
bit I'm just like I don't really know
which way to move my mouse or it's not
even matters I'm just kind of like
randomly doing it
I don't get consistent maybe she has a
twin out there pretty good but I can add
more details if I want cool I think I'm
ready to draw this that's a weird
question do you prefer wearing a rain
jacket or carrying an umbrella rain
jacket I never carry an umbrella
anywhere with me or just wear a hat
time to take the pan dude
that's nice I might know is that done
that's done oh no not you can draw no
mushroom okay got it
come on girl let's get back in do you
just walk through Daniel okay now okay
dinner's ready
getting sick of ravioli Wow Wow nothing
it's real food it's better than nothing
I'm just tired of the same thing do you
want it mushroom
we gonna eat though
Daniel come on I know hide my powers I
meant like you've gotta eat some food
puppy I don't want you to get in the
habit it might be making
sorry I'm cool hold on I need to show
you something um okay there's medicine
in the bathroom gotta show him the map
oh look I think I left it with my books
hmm nothing here where's your boots
Daniel what did you do with the map what
do you mean you know what I mean oh no
it's the man that was with my stuff
oh this map it's in my time sorry Sean
hey my dream nothing is like this no
it's not
mushroom shrim you're a cutie but please
take it away you stop being so damn cute
okay come on doggy let's go girl move
will be I think that's it and yeah hey
man can you call you dog I don't exist
mushroom me every day what a great team
here we go time to play dad talk
what the oh my god guys I just saw it
now
the web was life in the sturgeon
I'm just gonna don't worry and I know
it's it's probably just someone lost
another Daniel got you Jim yeah okay I
prank you I get a job you always [ __ ]
your pants I say cute man anyway
okay I think it's time for us to hit the
road you're not getting better we're
almost out of supplies no I'm okay it's
just a cough yeah a bad cough that won't
go away
trust me Daniel you need some medicine
look here
Eva treat what's that
that's where Karen's parents our
grandparents live okay
so what so we can go there and they'll
probably help us why do you always force
us to run Sean what if they don't like
me
they're family right plus they always
for what Karen for what mom did um you
sure it would be cool to spend Christmas
with our grandparents man they're kind
of love you grandpa super cool and I'm
sure you guys will be best buds well
okay but mushroom has to agree to she's
part of the team what do you say it girl
okay when tomorrow the sooner the better
we have a long road ahead hmm we should
do something fun for our last night here
how about a team with dice if I win I
get the draw on your backpack you know
I'm gonna win and draw a dick on your
bag right I don't think some loser
damn advice professional age which I
already enjoy for that much what's your
but I'll play another popular game if it
comes along like Resident Evil did well
and I'm ready a joint that was such a
good game so yeah I will play more
popular games but I have to enjoy them
as well no point watching someone play
again if they ain't having fun
Oh
here we go just need a six five and a
four oh sweet
did it use other ship
was the game was
[ __ ] is six-five is captain and four is
glue and then you can use the last
icicles and loot play with their highest
Luke - over 20 wins the game okay
this ship is mine
captain's ready to rule I have a crew
now here comes the loot
I want the six what I can I have to say
I score here you go cargo trait job
lover good luck beating that matey
don't worry about that all right your
turn
hey mark marks there unduly Louis Louis
Louie got a ship now I need a captain
come on come on give me something
anything
phew it was a close one
not bad I think I won yes
come on my cool give me the same okay
what the hell you're cheating you
kidding me
I can see the dice rolling dude
of course it's rolling you're throwing
it
you're too obvious man no point in
cheating if anyone can see it geez okay
need more practice cool
give me the same oh you gonna cheat
again
I wonder what we would have done if we
didn't find these days I don't know
probably read all these books you
remember that time I'd be dad at chess
you mean yeah you did help me distract
them huh
I bet he would have liked this dumb it
definitely I lost he was a great pirate
just like us
captain Diaz king of the Seas I'm so
much usual
all right I just need a for now
I'm glad Mach doesn't marry they're
[Music]
using trim on grandpa we'll have a
console uh I don't think so dude sorry
no biggie I like playing dice and stuff
too
whoa Daniel the big nerd getting sick of
screens no way it's nice for a change
hmm I want to I don't want my play box
yeah I bet I hope no us keeping our
minecraft forge us alive
hmm I'm sure he is pal no no way he gave
up your super kings oh yay no full ship
no score
all right your turn mushrooms growing up
so fast
really I don't see much difference well
she's still a tiny dog but I can tell
she's getting old and smart and I went
yes you do you know what it means
yeah okay you want it here's my bag mm
that's my bag let's see
yeah what do you yeah they get to draw
on each other's back oh that's cute you
have any mushroom yes I know but Knights
it's really cool dude thanks
so let's do another one nah it's bedtime
gotta get up early I'm gonna finish my
comic book okay
she has to pee okay okay I'll take her
out for a walk you're going this movie
is that raccoon gross
you're right don't smoke but it's our
last night so would you do anything
alright alright I heard you the first
time dude
it's gotta be freezing out there
[Music]
[Music]
my Sherman's up here
[Music]
[Music]
yeah so these are like
kind of the iconic parts of life is
strange just like it's like a movie on
the game all at once
[Music]
[Music]
Daniel's hide
[Music]
how long are they planning on staying
there
yeah Mike you probably watch episode 1
fast cuz none of this is gonna make
sense to you basically their dad is dead
because some racist stuff happened and
they're his little brother heard these
powers and accidentally killed the
police officer so they're like on the
run now hey Daniel that's the face of
the security doing such I'm coming
and they're trying to get down to but
the love of mushroom wants to go out of
family
don't you hear yeah sorry who
so what's going on doesn't fit in
there's too much stuff it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] hey cool down it's gonna be
okay
I know but what did you pack in what the
dude you can't fit the whole room in
don't worry you're super strong big
brother can help
awesome
thanks Shawn well looks like we're
almost set
where's mushroom leaving still peeing I
guess I'm gonna check what she's up to
okay I'll fill up our bottles and I'll
catch up with you guys not quite right
where's the drink
oh I did play broken age a very long
time ago mark yeah
nobody is gonna
oK we've got a water doesn't ever
actually finish burgomaster he's
impacted his he packed up his whole den
where the hell is he
come on Daniel Daniel hey you out here
Daniel
do I like motorcycles yeah sure I mean I
don't know how to ride one where is she
I did ride one once actually and I got
told but I shouldn't ride a bike because
I'm I go too fast it's fun though we
have a two-day walk ahead of us better
get going
Daniel where are you
down here
No I have to find Daniel in mushroom I
thought I thought what he was down there
maybe
maybe they what are they doing dude what
are you doing blood oh my god
what the [ __ ] happened here
Oh
it's under here
that's not good as mushrooms
whatever happened it must happen bloody
fast
Daniel what is that a bear oh my god oh
[ __ ]
Daniel do not calm down okay
listen ring hello
go away Oh
[Music]
you never die Daniel I'm so sorry just
wouldn't have changed anything to kill
it I'm right here
it's all right no that's not you so
saying
dogs never die in games well fable 2 I
think was my first experience of that
but now is the decision
you didn't have to let it go
here
you should do it
that's it
it's [ __ ] you can't even bear it
well unless you want to say something
where's the Evo dogs don't count
nice nice friendly dogs
goodbye mushroom they don't try and kill
you if you're such a good puppy I'll
always remember running through the snow
with you and how you snuggle and I'll
never forget you never
Thank You mushroom for looking after us
in these woods you won't be for kai-shan
he thinks she's up in heaven what's dad
yeah yeah I'm sure he will look after
her oh this is too much
wait what about his allergies don't
worry you know there's no allergy set
behind they'll be fine together okay we
should go
it's getting late
okay
mushroom
[Music]
[Music]
I wish we didn't have to go
I like our house again
come on
let's hit the room
[Music]
what about my traps
should we leave them up they'll protect
the next run always to stay here
[Music]
I put both you in charge of the house
mushroom
so long we dudes
[Music]
she was like a boy
[Music]
beside so long Madhu's
well I want to get better at guitar
whenever I listen to the life is change
sound tractors oh it's really nice
acoustic guitar music
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dear
[Music]
[Music]
still coffin
[Music]
[Music]
hmm on time No
[Music]
but I appreciate the acknowledgement
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so I think that ubirr will be way too
much actually you guys don't come where
I am
we made it Daniel all the time since I
was here Wow when was that before you
were born
we made it to petal mamas
Justin's under Christmas
come here let me check you out Claire
likes everything super clean dad said
she got pissed because he let me bring a
snowball in the house you don't want to
look like total pigs I already have
they're nice
okay hold up I need to pee was I
you
Neb a Ono market like this one turn out
well I don't think this is the end
there's gonna be I don't know GG about
four or five episodes I think so this
can't be the end
so yeah this is probably gonna end up
bad something's gonna happen the kid's
gonna run off Oh God what if they went
on vacation or something we'll figure
out something in the house I'm sorry we
don't want any of hello Claire
Sean is that Daniel look who's here
after all this time what the hell are
you doing here Steven
what's your mouth well it's kind of a
long story
poor thing
you know he's sick right yeah okay
inside both of you
okay they see my skies they seem nice
must be weird them like having a nice
warm house again finally
Hey is it warm enough for you oh yeah
feels nice and toasty
I gave Daniel some cough medicine but
you should have taken better care of him
they could have been worse you were
lucky
Stephen may I talk to you for a second
guess we haven't told it yet
I remember that I think it used to be in
the living room it's good to be inside
final walk did I make a mistake coming
here
no you just
[ __ ]
I'm so hungry my belliard's
isn't even Shana this sound good to be
here
are you alright honey you want more tea
thanks I'm good
well Sean you want to talk about the
police called us a few weeks ago
tell them I'm looking for you as
suspects in a homicide
yeah the police killed dad now if you
want us to help you
did you hurt that police officer in
Seattle
no the police killed bad I don't like
any of these responses seriously EE
skills that you really think I killed
that cop no don't don't get mad Sean we
have to ask we only know what we saw on
the news he shot dead they go no he's
gone no sweetie
we are so sorry for what happened to
your father
but why did you run away if you're
innocent
we had no choice the cops would have
blamed me for everything I know it well
Sean
now the police do blame you you know the
police would separate us maybe forever
Daniel would end up in foster care you
can't be sure Sean
anyway at least you've managed to come
here alive
we're glad I hate to think what could
have happened to both of you you need to
think of long-term solutions now I tried
I swear but I can't do everything that's
the nice so what are your plans
down to the Mexico go down to Mexico to
port the loose oh we haven't what that
has a family yeah just having a job you
can't run away from the law lightly like
fugitives how can you look out for your
brother if you're both running from the
police
you two are gonna stay with us
Oh Stephen maybe we should after your
mother left your dad never really wanted
us in your life I can't blame him but
you're still part of our family and by
their grandparents on the mother's side
so that's why they're not overly
understanding of the situation he just
cared really aren't you scared
the police already called you lordy yes
we're also scared for you that's why
you'll have to be careful around here
Beavercreek I'm school what happens the
grandparents
we can stay serious awesome
Oh Shawn guess what there's a huge model
train upstairs
hey you're supposed to be resting young
man yeah yes he is but he seems better
already anyway
you and Daniel will stay here at least
until Daniels better we'll see what
happens next so I bet you're hungry yeah
let me fix you see if it's that food oh
I wish someone would cook for me
how do you feel super wolf yeah feels
good feeling better you look cozy yeah I
love that bed thanks grandma good your
temperature is down I'm you still need
to take it easy how about if we say a
little prayer and give thanks it's like
a bedtime story right well this is a bit
like this
yes except the story comes from up there
the ceiling mmm-hmm so are we ready to
pray just follow my lead
sure we need all the help we can get
can you ask the Blessed dad and Sean and
mushroom in you and Grandpa and
everybody else oh my you are so sweet
thank you Lord for bringing Shawn and
Daniel's safe and sound into our house
take care of Esteban and mushroom please
give us the strength to get over the
hardships of the past and the trials yet
to come amen amen amen
okay sweetie nice it's bedtime try to
get some rest you still need it and no
roughhousing in here no worries we're
too tired
good night oh and thanks again good
night grandma
then they love those tacky Christmas
decorations
my grandma would never have that in the
bathroom here's that particular plus you
don't smell anymore
whatever well Claire seems pretty caring
and nice
I guess Stephen is too I hope we'll be
fine yeah I think so and the more
important thing is you'll have time to
get better Sean
no I don't think this is the one not
from what I remember but it's been a
while
could we check it out tomorrow maybe
find some of her stuff
wait what did I was that remember I just
don't know anything about it did you die
I understand but we need to focus on
where we are now and we're off to mom
left us yes she made her choice
we gotta make ours we can't keep going
back you know what I mean yeah
I guess hey man you've been doing so
great with your well you know I was
wondering how do you do it uh I don't
know I concentrate in it just happens
wait does it hurt no it's kinda itchy
though and it's rusty
sorry anyway remember the rules right
we really don't want Claire Steven to
start asking questions I know I know
hey Jo sue don't show us well just keep
that in mind and everything should be
fine sleep tight
it'll come
I'm doing good I'm just having a lazy
day yes
how are you
it seems too good to be true I'm just
waiting for the next really bad thing I
mean can't be as bad as mushrooms death
where's it gone what's doing she's gonna
accidentally do something it's one of
them isn't
yeah I don't know right now I'm not
thinking that that grandparents will rat
them out but yeah I could sleep all day
long in this bed because they are
extremely religious which shows that
they have extremely fixed morals so I
don't know I missed that dirty little
dog so much more than I thought I would
that's cool Claire dug this up for us
that's such a baller in his suit this is
pretty good so far I love it Steven only
has crime and trained books
and we're walking around new boxes
all right I'm allowed to go out now
that's a cool memento of art secret
cabbing in the woods
go downstairs and have breakfast that's
my objective yeah Daniel knows how to
milk Ranma for toys good he deserts to
Britannia was training his precision
with ease [ __ ] awesome Daniel looks
like a toll thug in his new pyjamas
finally I'm glad they get along so big
so careful chief going late on schedule
yeah but we're gonna scare the
passengers away what's up ah look who's
here but you're too late for the 9:15
Express it's okay I'll take the next one
it will leave after breakfast thanks for
following hiding the light this time Hey
look at I won't
can't believe it's already like I broke
this thing really made 10 years ago we
reached it ain't kept it oh this is
dismissive in their mum's bedroom
I better not sneak in they won't like it
maybe always at that bedroom it's been
locked ever since we got here
I don't give a [ __ ] yeah sounds like it
is
oh man Lenny water how did we survive
for weeks out there with no hot water
should we do the dirty laundry he sure
did stalk us up on clothes for the
winter I used to hate brushing my teeth
just like Daniel now I can't get enough
toothpaste
I hope I'll never have to hold on to
Bart to take a [ __ ] we'll all be that
one day we have so many pills and stuff
to take sucks to be old okay
how do we how do we get downstairs and I
hit the kitchen quick
Claire's waiting for us
Stephen doesn't like us in here when
he's away he's mine the workroom work Oh
My look who's awake good morning
sleepyhead it's that bad feels like a
cloud I know you can sit down Shawn
aren't you hungry wait you have a nice
house
it's cold took us in but how long are we
gonna stay here Daniel breakfast time
your brother is ready Stephen your
grandson needs to eat now you can show
him the boxcar later I love how they're
getting along you need help or anything
oh don't worry I can do this in the dark
thanks for the offer all right all right
are you boys done playing we had a
express delivery with the passengers
what yep has to go straight to the
workshop good no trains in the kitchen
remember gotcha chief
[Music]
ah sugar he can fix his trains but not
my kitchen make enough everything's okay
it's great as usual you're the best
trick ever
looks like you're getting cozy with this
new country life after all well they've
only been to one night yeah it's nice to
be far away from everything feels like
we're the only ones out here well that's
exactly why we love it it feels safe oh
I get it
this is tying in with like the amazing
evolution so whatever the right you'd
get along good bury our neighbors we try
to live the joy Emma like to Charles
next door he lost his wife and things
have been hard on him and his son he
would just get lost in Seattle but we're
all taking care of him here how old is
his son III think he's your age
yeah oh the one with the Cape and like
Joseph stuff so we're gonna be on the
other side of that now saving him when
he falls because his dad is an alcoholic
stop stop stop stop stop crazy hey
what's going on back there
nothing oh I thought Stephen was a fast
eater hey grandma I wanted to ask you
something about that locked room
upstairs I told you there is nothing to
see in it
do you know why were you in it this
morning then because there's a lot of
old junk in there and besides it's not
safe for you to explore okay Daniel
language why don't you go explore
outside you sure look like you're
getting better get some fresh air
I'll wait for Sean and then we'll go we
won't be loud but be careful nobody sees
you yeah baby
do you know I mean Nikki they the DLC
for life is strange the first one was it
caught it was like the adventure they
should have attained was care insuring
and maybe you should tell him to watch
his mouth
I did tell him to watch his mouth
nothing to see
Daniel needs that he doesn't know
anything about her I know poor thing but
his mother isn't in there anymore so
nobody goes in the room okay did the mom
Jewish
her parents as well does she just like
she did mom ever contact you just left
everyone she only talked to dad a few
times and she was gone
yeah she was you know Shawn I don't
really want to talk about this anymore
it's over you have to respect my rules
under my roof okay
that's the one the also Avengers Captain
Spirit I knew it was like a swear
something adventurous something okay of
course always
I appreciate that Shawn now you better
go find your brother
there's a shed with some old toys
outside to hell that Stephen has the key
taniel freak thank you
what's the point in this game ten lines
it's basically like um it's a narrative
based game so unlike other games with
like kill things gain all the points
only good go die
this is more like look around do the
things get to know the game with Stephen
and get those keys and you get to
Daniel's going up stakes decisions come
like this hello same get tailgate yeah
telltale games but yeah this is the
second one of the first of life is
strange so G member I don't know if you
ever heard of life is strange where
there's always a power that's involved
so in the first life of strange you can
through buying time but now your brother
has the ability to pick things up the
clearanced even are super kind to us but
a bit smothering I find it really
difficult to talk to you guys and I play
this game because they always talk like
all the time but yeah so it's basically
just a narrative driven game
okay sorry for getting upset Sean okay I
just don't feel comfortable talking
about it's it's fine really I don't have
to I'm glad I picked these up gives me
something to work on when they're all
watching TV such a big fireplace they're
not he did London
that's luxury beautiful hey Claire
what's on your mind Sean
what did you think of dad you can tell
me I won't get mad oh well your father
was he was his own person that's it I
mean I know you guys didn't really get
along
it's just Esteban was very different
from us and he never took a single step
to change any of that
did you I wish we would have some
bridges you can't cross I can only live
with regrets now don't worry you guys
taking care of fusses oh you would have
warned that's a very kind thing of you
to say Shawn thank you do you know
anything about dad's funeral there was a
service
we couldn't make it in time oh but we
sent flowers I'm sorry Shawn it's okay I
just want to make sure somebody took
care of him hopefully you can go visit
him at some point
at some point yeah how long have you and
Steven been married
oh my forever oh but a good forever
almost 40 years and that's more than
twice my age you both were married
during y2k thanks for making me feel
even older I assumed you must have a
girlfriend or almost started dating this
one person but I guess not anymore I
understand I'm sorry honey
it's not fair that you have to deal with
all this things will change
I hope what's the story with your
neighbor Charles poor man used to be a
basketball coach but had to move out
here after his wife's passing he's got a
job at the rail yard now and well he's
still recovering Wow I mean that's sad
we tried to give him a hand keep an eye
on his drinking problem his son Chris is
a little angel though I think Daniel
would be a good influence on him he's
got a great role model after all Thanks
I'm trying my best
okay go thanks Claire
you are very hey Joe Quinn it's always a
pleasure to speak with my grandson's and
yummy warmer have you ever seen any
actual fish in there I need a handy
assistant can you hand me the glue in
the cupboard okay whoa careful sorry I
forgot that thing isn't too stable okay
sorry my fault your grandmother keeps
telling me but I'm a lazy old man hey
can you close the door I want to talk
for a second oh uh it's the power cable
of course yeah that happens all the time
so listen I've noticed things with
Daniel you know what I'm talking about
Cathy Cooper anything right now well I'm
not sure how to put it like some kind of
invisible holy gift yeah Daniel likes to
pretend he's got superpowers but that's
it
that's it okay but be careful Shaun he's
still so young
sure now by the way let's keep this
between us
Claire has a lot of strong beliefs she
adores saying hell now and just once
both of you to be safe and happy what
I'm trying to say is maybe you should
stay here with us I know you boys plan
to run to Mexico but
but we have a home important ovo's what
the Lobos dad I wanted to return there
to Mexican boys out on the rum that
won't be a secret in Beavercreek for
long
America is your home with us and you
have to think about your brother his
future - all that stuff it's too
dangerous for us to stay here and for
you guys - it's dangerous to be on the
road do you think your father would have
wanted this for his kids I'm not gonna
start yelling of course not but
everything's different now
I know I know well just think about it
but don't torture yourself
I will hey Claire said you had the keys
for the toolshed
oh sure here you guys enjoy the Sun and
be careful with that shed it's probably
hot mess inside Thanks okay let's go
outside and save the freight really why
why no idea but you're a big boy now you
can take a look around
I won't eat yet cool sorry Sean I know
you guys miss your games and your web
sites a break from all this can only do
you good you know it's it's safer that
way
yeah no one wants a spoiler
Stevan sure takes his hobby
says mom when she was young
oh you found this uh yeah I just forgot
to it's okay it's been a while since
I've seen her face yeah I like taking a
look at it from time to tell her why did
she hurt why did she go yeah it does
but she's still my daughter you know I
can't prove what she's done but I I
think I understand good
I don't
yeah sorry Joe please don't please don't
say anything to Claire about this okay
don't worry I won't yeah like why does
she get this is just someone to mislead
oh that's what the kid takes it was our
neighbor's son Chris yeah I helped him
when his dad build that treehouse why
are you holding a fire sword yeah that
kid sure has an imagination
Wow is that you oh yeah that was taken
when I retired the mayor came to
congratulate me up settle that's awesome
yeah really great how come you have a
disco ball are you like throwing parties
and stuff Claire told me you guys have
been married for like 40 years so it
kind of makes sense that's even why do
you are Shawn got the key hey I have to
go out and run some errands can you do
me a big favor
do you know how to work a washing
machine since I was about eight of
course can you throw in yours and your
brothers clothes after the next load
they're in the bathroom basket
totally yeah no problem thank you so
much
feel free to start tidying your stuff
too it's good for the house to keep a
house clean
definitely Daniel can help uh and
remember for your own safety no phone
and no internet I know I know
boring rules don't worry Claire
hey Daniel yeah Sam ed could work for
you busy my ass come over here geez you
know I'm gonna find you
what is the washing machine stuff anyway
tidy up this board game see you tonight
buddy
I don't know when Daniel will be able to
go back to his school
not in there
it was done here
how its ready doc I can't see anything
I get that he's sick of all this [ __ ]
but come on I need help it's always with
Claire I can't really tell this is cute
or bossy she's leaving her husband roles
on how to use the washing machine
gotcha
I can't find him wait is he see in
cupboard yeah pretty different from the
one we had back at home how grandparents
the third thing to do was hug
grandparents mmm Claire could totally be
on one of those cooking shows she would
be brutal where are you boy hey you can
come out I'll do it myself here you are
thanks for nothing correction you're too
old to be a little brat it's cool that
Claire does her little paintings there
you are
whoa look at all these decorations
I heard Claire rehearsed some songs
she's got the groove
go and get our clothes time to take care
of that long hey what's up Oh
so you actually showed up one time I'm
new to the job but I'm ready chief I
remember playing this when I came here
years ago man things were so different
back then
zum-zum zum-zum train guy super fast
super fast huh sounds like something
stuck in that tunnel this model is so
amazing it's crazy
okay let's try it again is there
something in there
oh no that's fine
watch out the trend is going to derail
ooh
there actually was something stuck in
there you like a souvenir
creepy
this toy train is kind of
what doesn't squished his head on the
shelf
what what one doing out we stopped our
training session since we got here so
sucks
all right let's get it over with me
every weekend that I have to pain the
house which was this weekend by the way
how many programs does this thing have
okay hey will do preserve energy turn
off the light
okay time to burn off some calories what
do you say haha yes
Aparri you nearly hit his head when he
looked for Daniel in the cupboard
I don't know what Daniel was I think
he's in the toilet oh man finally feels
so good to be outside
reminds me of the cabin right watch out
for the pack
we
what are we doing now
so that's the treehouse TV helped out
with pretty awesome neighbors
[Music]
are you ever getting that toys out of
the show cat ready for storage wars
what's wrong frozen shut
of course Sean look Navin
saved him
good did you see that
yeah we did yeah we did it looks like
you're okay though
you're almost floating I I was I was I
could feel myself in the air it was
awesome that t-shirt are you a kid who's
your favorite superhero I love I have
the mega power bear you should check it
out dude that's so cool
Chris Oh God look I am so sorry are you
okay dad I'm fine I promise
are you sure listen I shouldn't do you
know them it's okay dad they're cool
he loves superheroes even Power bear ah
gotcha
hey there are you staying with the
Reynolds
there oh yeah there are grandparents
I see how jeez Chris you don't have any
damn shoes on I'm sorry buddy let's get
you inside
I yeah okay dad thanks guys
oh and uh if Claire asks tell her
everything is fine it is it really never
mind
see you around sure sure I remember
playing that likes guys later
yes we were going through a lot of
demons did you forget everything about
the rules already sorry Sean run who's
gonna hurt himself did you want me to
let you fall
really
no you you did the right thing but
listen we can't let anybody know we have
to keep a low profile out here he's like
my age I bet you would have done the
same exact thing
don't be mad I'm not mad dude it's it's
over
Daniel remember that we're hiding out so
no training and no showing off your
power yes from now on you stick with me
all the time okay
there's also granddad nose and you
should not know
and don't worry [ __ ] Jo Quinn Jo Quinn
you're still much better English than I
am any other language and for even
pronouncing your name probably because
I'm sure I'm butchering it is that power
there there's not like where
no it's not that spare about on the on
the wall on the poster
I am at the neighbors [ __ ] so much for
staying with me I shine
okay time to get Daniel at the
Erickson's
let's get dressed wear the same clothes
again again again
Claire Steven anybody home
wait
the rooms not on notes yeah this well
looks like I'm home alone
will be greatly
oh right Sunday morning
Clarence Steven must be a church we had
a good time decorating the tree together
last night
Daniel loved it cute
okay are we gonna go out the back way of
the front way well I guess they won't be
back for at least two hours back by noon
for lunch see an event love come on girl
pop yes cuz she's right good job kids PS
PS yes I thank you for the outfit maybe
I could use Stevens laptop no it's been
ages since I've had news from the real
world
I could just delete my browser history
after I'm done no I'm gonna be a good
good grandson I'm not going to do it and
since Queen Stephen and Claire are gonna
freak if they realize he went to the
Erickson's go outside my doing gout son
get outside
Oh am I
wait what how am I supposed to do this
just want to leave the house please
here we go
hey evil Oh Kristen hey let's get this
back back home now thanks for coming to
the live stream
did any of you see me play the DLC why
does Daniel never listen maybe I'm too
soft with him and I thought Daniel was
the crafty one
ah what's going on here
Sean wait don't freak out I can explain
let me tell him Sean I know it sounds
crazy but I have a superpower you saw me
yesterday I know you did
I'm always making you know this morning
I can move things objects with my mind
Oh superpower really yes
not to say it's free and you don't
realize what that implies everyone can
see you from the outside puppy room this
is dangerous
do you understand yes we hear you we
promise to be careful this is just our
secret okay nobody can find out I'm the
real captain spirit and nobody will ever
now you're an official member of the
Spirit Squad if you betray us I'll
disintegrate you nah just kidding oh
yeah we need a team signal totally I'm
gonna be super wolf he's like what's
your super name Shawn Oh what should I
be guys
silver from El Diablo Loco professor
Diaz no I don't know they're all pretty
bad
[Music]
oh yeah I don't know something cool like
LDS blow loco
sounds like a supervillains name yeah
maybe a bit okay okay guys I think we're
ready to roll uh excuse me who are you
I'm Shawn oh yeah sorry man
you're here for Daniel hey let's make it
official I'm Charles Erickson nice to
meet you
hope you know that Daniel and Chris are
a dangerous team we better watch out or
they're gonna take over the world
yeah they share a lot of things that's
because these can we go get the
Christmas tree now we're both ready to
fly yes yes yes the team has been
waiting too long
hey you should come along too there's
nothing going on over here
yes can't wait to see all the
decorations and Shawn we can't buy
Christmas presents for Grandma and
Grandpa
they will worry I mean and has no I
haven't done anything fun since I
dropped the sick it's the first time
I've been out for days we won't be gone
for long the markets only a few miles
away anyway they'll be at the service
for at least another hour anyway yeah
Shawn I can show Daniel around you can
come with us please say yes please
please please
[Music]
okay you win not a fair fight
so let's go Daniel can fly give me to
clean up the backseat I'll honk when I'm
done oh but captain spirit doesn't use
the bathroom it's not actually happening
I think you'll see my comic books I'm
glad you're coming too
hey you want to see my toys
Oh score the new hot dog man since
you're a new member of the team you have
to know everybody
these are captain spirits friends and
his enemies dude that's pretty cool can
you guess who are the good guys and the
villains let's see hmm
I think the pirate is a villain I think
oh well obviously I know the bear is a
hero because I know you love your bear
look closely oh wait do they all have
light to the or share the bad guys the
good guys not that easy right
maybe the pyrrha is a hero I don't know
what questioning everything careful it
may be tricky
look closely what about Stein doing the
car
Carnot's a bit evil the bad guys the
good guys maybe he's right maybe Dino
was a good guy
careful it may be tricky okay how did I
do not bad
you're almost right it was a bit tricky
okay let me introduce them to you
this is team spirit the good guy the
pirate or the forest warrior power bear
Marty Rex and sky pirate so who are the
bad guys that's not Tereus and the sharp
stinger there's also other than me too
but he's out in the garden but they're
all working for mandroid
who's the real supervillain so where is
he hiding out on his evil planet waiting
for me but captain spirit and super wolf
will make sure he doesn't hurt anyone
yeah strength in numbers sounds like
mandroid is in trouble just wait until
he sees what happened spirit can do now
yeah about that
does your father does your dad know
about any of this did he see something
yesterday no he didn't see anything and
the power didn't work yesterday after I
so must have been too tired okay good um
I mean he could be pretty disturbed if
he knew oh definitely not
telling dad I don't want to freak him
out he's worried about other stuff
anyway Chris it's none of my business
but are you and your dad okay uh what do
you mean I don't know Claire seems to be
worried about you guys
Claire is always worried we're cool
totally he's just he you know has a hard
time being on his own that's all
Chris I know life can get pretty tough
trust me but
you'll be okay the little toy has but
he's evil purple toy has a butt but I
don't feel scared anymore
I have the power and I have Daniel sorry
the water eater is still broken there's
the signal
come on Daniel Hey
protip don't go in there yeah okay squad
let's roll and what this game is really
good if you just want to chill out and
just I know I guess like watch a movie
bolsa play a game reward you're catching
another call
no I'm good thanks and don't be waving
your arms around when I'm driving okay
yeah um remember Daniel don't mess
around
this soundtracks to these games are
always
so something's gonna happen to the wall
that out I guess that means that they
don't make it back to their Grandma and
Grandpa's and they have to be back on
the road
that's my core I'm calling it for easy
[Music]
[Music]
yeah cuz I guess they're going into the
city aren't they so they've got much
more chance of getting noticed because
they are on the run don't forget hey
Danny is still here
[Music]
I don't have winter snow ties we don't
really need them where I'm from it
doesn't really snow that much okay buddy
when it does you're like what do we do
so no bread hmm hey you guys go ahead
and we'll come back to meet you okay
brothers meeting sure don't get lost
dude what the [ __ ] are you doing I can't
believe it how many times do we have to
keep going over the rules don't show the
power I know
but Chris thinks he can do all this cool
stuff I wish he could he reminds me of
no one I just miss having friends Shawn
[Music]
ah wait I don't know I don't understand
stop lying to Chris so stop telling
Chris that he has powers or protect the
secret and he'll be like yeah I'll
protect your secret but then if he stops
find Chris does he have to tell Chris
the truth well you would have to tell
Chris I know that I have to select a
choice it's prompted me to slice what
should we choose I don't know guys can
you help me can you help me can you help
me
I joke with that's quite mean of you to
say about everyone watching okay I'm
gonna go toilet again
and then when I come back hopefully you
guys can help me with what choice I
should be making please thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
I know man but you can't lie to friends
about something like this he could get
in trouble thinking you can make [ __ ]
fly or he could get hurt
so you want me to tell him the truth
well I don't want you to lie anymore
you don't have to tell him everything
but don't let him think he has magic
powers okay
you swear thank you okay deal
Thank You Dustin I'm counting on you and
I know can I go see Chris now yeah let's
go but don't forget what I say just so
you know um I said to stop lying because
I didn't want Chris to do anything to
hurt himself it looked like giant
cocoons
you told me Shawn don't worry
I'll be your Island
snowman wasn't that creepy after all
come on no time to lose okay just pick
the one you like and come get me
deal looks like someone went nuts over
these box will have to tame the one you
want I wonder what will happen to the
trees no one pies will they get
replanted
dear Santa we've been good kids this
year please explain this ha bass is that
a yo-yo
Daniel had one back home I found here
the other day and I can still do it a
Cavalier and you-you'd from Seattle
don't know if I can get used to it
whoa
the guy who painted that must have been
seriously I think you're me Hey
that's not much but she probably needs
it more than me right now
hey I was supposed to listen to you are
you can start
it's me it's me you've come to take my
[Music]
eggs
[Music]
for me we play the game skillful hands
and so I asked for
me
and he chased us back
so the my hands sweat
and I was looking for a way to describe
[Music]
oh that's a sweet Russell and his wife
watch me that's like where you made it
all the way through weird you got a
crush on me or something well I just
like good music no I I mean it was
pretty cool i I just relax dude it's a
cool that you listened people are
usually too busy to care you have a
great voice you should be on one of
those singing shows that's kinda nice oh
really my thing though I hate TV show
business [ __ ] well thanks for the music
and good luck see ya
I've already given her money
hey you're gonna speak to now she's like
her friend a singing friend miss me
already
yep what no I mean I'm just I wear a
change maybe my friends have been
crashing here for the wait nobody gives
a [ __ ] about us
yeah I can tell you're not from around
here
no no way just here for the holidays ah
you got family my grandparents I don't
love the grandparents what about you and
your friends road trip uh not really
we gotta hop from place to place
hunting for little jobs and just be
alone right that's okay
we hop on trains here's us time to rest
damn that sounds kind of dangerous
not really you can run and jump you're
pretty much good to go
well unless you get caught or fall but
we've been lucky so far that's the best
nobody tells us what to do no
corporation owns oh and you get to see
so many cool places exactly
next stop is Humboldt County California
stoner break it's not even close
we actually got work over there Shawn
what are you doing we've hit the
treatment trace it's all crooked like an
old wish um hi who are you Oh your hair
looks so cool is it with what do you
think I don't know but it's really cool
I'm Daniel what's your name
hi Daniel I'm Cassidy I dig your
superhero outfit I'm on a secret mission
with my friend it's very dangerous
I can do I hope you get your mission
accomplished and what's your name
Oh Shawn I I thought I told you no you
did sorry you went through some [ __ ]
with the guys how much you make you
ready
hello pups oh is that your doggie so
cool yeah he's been through a lot and he
stinks yeah you stink and you like it
huh he's not the only one
have you checked your hair I think it
just twitched you should keep your
distance dude
she looks really cool I think
he knows I'm clean you're the nasty yeah
you always go for those suburban boys
are you kidding you want to talk about
your scoreboard hotshot hey no worries
come on let's bail jealous you Sean and
Daniel stay out of trouble kids hope we
see you on the rail
someday yeah see you around doggy was so
cute I miss mushroom I miss her too hey
excuse me
dogs have to be on a leash around here
too many strays sorry dude
we don't do leashes well the city does
then unleash dog is liable to a fine so
you're gonna find our dog well that's
not very nice loitering is illegal too
and you don't live here right right calm
down sweetie we're allowed to visit the
Christmas market my dogs not gonna eat
you look at him you better watch your
mouth you Punk's are always causing
trouble this is a nice town okay guys
someone needs to get laid
he's out of pills that's it I'm calling
the cops
Oh God he's gonna call the cops on us
Finn chill out we're leaving this
[ __ ] anyway you guys don't even have
a Santa for chrissake
Merry Christmas [ __ ] parasites why
did they fight I don't know why he tells
like that should we do something about
it No
[Music]
no note with his power no no no better
not get involved man this guy doesn't
look nice you're right
we could have pranked him without us
however I'm guessing they were he would
have used his power and he would have
start using his power more and like
stuff I can talk to him use my work what
sorry getting tired of these parasites
if you know what I mean
not really just tired of lazy people you
know just waiting for useless
governments to feed them hey you look
smart you should check this out it's not
conspiracy stuff huh swear no thanks
sorry why don't you care about our
country's future yeah in my own way but
not like that
I get it you Millennials want everything
for free that's not how we built this
country like those Punk's you were with
they're nothing but trouble you better
be careful I don't know they're not
hurting anyone they live differently
that's all plus your music was really
beautiful it's great to live off your
talents but come on they're not
achieving anything hey man you got a
dollar is not fighting the power this is
why our country is broken deadbeats
you don't know anything about them
you're just judging them
no I'm judging their actions they don't
deserve this country well it's their
country too okay smartass I see where
this is going
as usual sorry to bug you hey no worries
I don't mind talking about that stuff
good luck with everything
good luck why are you sleepy then he's a
dick [ __ ] believable yeah always the
same thing with these beat hey hi good
morning young man
it's nice to see a new face in this old
town you would just Vince be mean super
cool market you got here small towns are
the best for Christmas who are you
staying with the Reynolds everybody know
Stephen he was beaver Creek's fire chief
years ago uh you're not his grandson are
you oh no he's just an old family friend
gotcha anyway welcome to Beaver Creek if
you need anything just holler
we only sell handmade local products
what should I buy for the grandparents
guys I don't have enough money did you
see that un-fuckin'-believable
yeah always the same thing with these
people I wasn't such a jerk teenager
um I'd like one of those snowmen thanks
of course they're handmade by local kids
cool here you go
Thanks anything else no okay have a nice
day then
yeah you too Thanks yeah well wait
Ashikaga wished you better yeah how's it
my way before couldn't ice doesn't come
back what are you doing
hi everybody we're taking a year off to
run away from cops Daniel has got
telekinesis now hope you're doing well
[Music]
do your Santa whipping it's this year
please explain man it would have been so
cool to have one of these before coming
here did you see that on [ __ ]
believable yeah thing with these people
I wasn't such a jerk
where are they
darling
now hey there hey you guys ready to go
yeah all done cool
hop in are you having too much fun back
there that's what I thought
okay what's gonna happen sister
looks like Daniel found a new brother
no kitty yeah I'm like a rock I'm glad
you two came along it's great that Chris
found a new friend out here it looks
like you did too what's her name um
Cassidy Cassidy cute name do you like
her she was cool yeah it's good for me
to get out too
we've had a rough time over the past
couple of years my wife Emily she died
two years ago obviously it was tough on
Chris [ __ ] I'm sorry man
Thanks it's been a struggle especially
trying to be a good dad
do you have some kind of problems I'm
just not the man I was
she never even brought this up you know
just forget it no worries didn't want me
to feel bad we all have our ups and
downs right that's how life works
your grandparents sure did have their
share of downs too but they're always
there for us for Chris they seem like
good people
[ __ ] lies yeah I mean I'm my mom left
my dad a long time ago she never came
back
she broke all ties with her parents -
sorry for bringing that up
it's okay I hope they don't stress out
because we haven't come back yeah we
should get you two home don't keep them
waiting
yeah yeah see you later super wolf
hello hello they still not back
Claire Stephen looks like Grandma and
Grandpa haven't come back from church
yet
well at least they won't yell at us for
going out I was so cool to spend time
with Chris at the market so did she set
things straight with him told him the
truth
yeah yeah he was disappointed of course
he was you liked him
did you know Chris his mom was an artist
I didn't how so
she drew comics you should see her
drawings they're so cool just like yours
thanks dude hey what what is it Shawn I
want to go check on the room upstairs
I know it's moms please
they'll freak out Daniel you heard
Claire they will freak out if they know
we went inside we won't tell them we'll
be in total stealth mode they won't know
anything we make it quick it's just I
really want to know what's inside what
kind of stuff she Ana
Chris has tons of things that belong to
his mom and I have nothing come on Sean
you don't even have to come with me if
you don't want to [ __ ] I'll come with
you
so you don't make a mess and get us
caught
we'll find a way to open it Shawn this
is super easy I can just break the lock
with my power no yeah I could do that
with a hammer
let's try and find the key instead all
right
sharp objects bit like Claire
yeah no no way I'm searching Claire's
underwear Karen hated collecting
trinkets
she's to say they were just useless dust
traps come on Loki don't be shy
definitely not the one way too small
what can I put it back but let's see
what it opens
No put it back I didn't want to take
things it's not even in here wonder what
would have been different if dad had
taken us to church
how much more Irish can you be it just
it oh I'm just looking for a key not the
crown jewels you are these teeth not
sure if it's gross or cute but still
okey here
nananana okay Stephen where do you hide
this key I don't really see Stephen
listening to old-school pop rock music
we clearly don't share politics but at
least even doesn't preach yeah not much
to see in here
clothes old stuff definitely no hidden
key maybe it's some in the portrait baby
these are Christmas presents must not
tell Dana heart he'd freak okay yeah
maybe it's in this one come on you this
sweet little muffin would turn into such
a brat
still super cute though I love the
outfits guys man he looks so different
so urine I think everywhere
[Music]
okay Daniel think hard
what was she wearing dude your rock this
whole house is pretty much a huge
washing machine why does he want croon
bring the sweater how do you think he
might be in her sweater that might be in
here
cold no there's no box up here
small town hero starter pack [ __ ] wish I
had the Karen's smile on this picture
kind of reminds me of Daniels that would
have been really useful when we lived in
the woods I don't know I don't know it's
cute
[Music]
come on
what is this card again no way she were
to church
so close the door so they never know
gotta find a way to open that door or
Daniels gonna keep her antic about it
what so I can't go downstairs it says oh
that's the cardigan hey I think that's
the cardigan Claire was wearing
yesterday yes
I found one key so
it better fit just try it
Wow
there's not that much left
where do you think they put the rest of
her stuff
it's her teenage room I'm sure she
sorted through her things before leaving
for Seattle the rest has probably packed
in these boxes
I miss my music
I think it's not plugged
this playlist is boring as hell
probably took all her good ones
Karen liked to take pictures of
strangers when we walk down the streets
I miss my skateboard and going over the
park I think I saw a moon eclipse once
you've seen everything before Daniel was
born Steven will be home soon now ken
was still with us that penpal sure loved
listening to her on board he's so much I
thought you might have forgotten your
pal pal pal pal pen pals
it's so boring out here and your life is
the best thing ever you you were saying
you are you get very lonely too
sometimes the people group so glad we
found each other it's funny not that I
have this big family but I'm so jealous
of you for being an only child you get
the whole house to yourself with Queen I
told you before how stupid my brother
Ketan is such an immature boy even
though he's the oldest of all my
siblings he thinks he's so cool now just
because he has a driver's license
whatever just wait till we can't ride
then we can finally be say to that I
hear my dad yelling about some things I
got about before he gets me please write
back soon okay no idea whoever is
was carving Wow figures can was already
looking for an exit because they made
them sad yeah
dad did the same thing too
never seen any picture
okay now we can listen to music
the [ __ ] is wrong with these Oh hiding
spot smart so Karen was already serious
about running away to New York why did
you wait that long
I hope you enjoyed your trips so you
didn't pee on us for nothing I don't
think she used any perfume Oh
read a lot of these in the 10th grade I
know a nun yeah you finally left forever
I hear the green choir singing in the
forest in the ancient grave wrapping me
in there would spell their song the
roots light fuses that exploding in the
breast when I hide in my hearts hearing
that sound that makes me feel older than
the forest older than you but younger
than the climbs over at my feet if I
stirred into the soil with the voices
muffled like my faith in the pillars and
nobody knows I'm there I could sneak in
through the wormholes but that would
only lead down so over the treetops over
the river I feel myself leaving forever
these pictures are several random
they're not sunglasses man it's to look
at the Sun it's a clip he looked happy
they're not sunglasses man it's to look
at the Sun during eclipses flip says you
know when the Sun hides behind the moon
yeah so I think I remember that can
showed it to me once you hey check this
out
his name is alesis like the hero I guess
so cool they want to forget anything
related to Karen hmm I can relate
hi manfist she wasn't in New Age
[ __ ] okay should we get out now I
feel like on edge shortly enough
oh god Nicky the keys in Prague no
flashbacks never been a big fan of
hiking but here I was walking my way
down tonight
dozen esse why would clear lock these up
in here
hey Albert yeah I'll update perfection
after my EPS out I'm kind of doing it
like it's out from on bit by bit by bit
but don't worry and if you join the
discord in the description and I will
put updates in there
Oh Twitter Otis update you guys when I
got what's just say read it seriously
stop here how about this I've heard the
news about Seattle please help my boys
if they come oh she sided behind this
mouse I don't know you can reach me at
this address it's a P o box I use
sometimes
what's a P o box well a cop app so she's
following what I'm hearing beg you
please help my son's oh yeah right
total [ __ ] what do you mean she
cares about us
well I don't maybe she changed your mind
we could try and contact her you don't
even know her okay
don't get any wrong ideas we should just
stick to our plan for now can I read it
again
yeah then we got a good goodness oh [ __ ]
excuse me what are you both doing in
here except visibly ransacking our house
while we're at church - st. Claire no no
no Steven they went way out of line here
we specifically told you to stay out of
this room I just wanted to see my mom
stop this isn't her room anymore there
is nothing to see him here it's time you
learn to respect some rules actually we
did find something yeah I found a new
letter from my mom
she said she wants to see us but you
didn't even tell us she's not my
daughter anymore or your mother she
burned all those bridges one letter
doesn't change what she did to me all of
us she is not welcome back
just don't blame us for being curious
about it but I know her better than
anybody she hasn't changed she just
feels guilty I can't hear that listen
Sean I know life has been tough on you
the past month where's your souls and if
we put up with a lot of things but that
going through our stuff my personal
belongings
oh that shows you don't go to jail just
for helping you this is how you pay us
back
well things are just gonna change around
here if you want to stay man I think I
see why mom left now
she got holed up with your stupid rules
anymore oh so that's what you think
then let me tell you something
oh [ __ ] get this goddamn three-on-three
not the wardroom shouldn't tell you
about this no stop my legs
uh he's like do I use my power like what
do I don't um Oh guys what should we do
what should we do should we what you
would do would you would you would you
would you
I don't know I'm waiting for like to to
catch up I don't know if anyone's even
in the chat anymore this is why I play
the games with these so you couldn't
tell me what to do because I'm ready but
I know it's prompting me now so just use
the power I mean he's gonna power for a
reason but she would freak but and also
we're like saving a garden okay find him
I'm using it do it Daniel
now do what what's going on okay well so
I said using Joey Daniel
[Music]
don't drop it again that would be bad
no Nikki the grandma Claire didn't know
about the power button the grandma told
by baby Steven are you okay no thanks to
Daniel
oh you were right Claire
I should have fixed that covered months
ago I guess my laziness will get me
something what in the name of God was
that all about
that's impossible what are you Daniel
Claire listen they saved me Claire
that's all that matters
maybe it was a miracle
thank you lord
no Shawn I didn't we didn't call them I
know grandma
Shawn what are we gonna do go hide in
the garage no no no way if the police
are just the house that makes the two of
you accomplices your bags and go out the
back door I'll distract him
really yes no get the hell out of here
so sorry for everything I wish we could
have helped you more I wish you could
stay here with us watch out for your
brother Shawn yes be careful I'll see
you soon
thanks for helping us both of you oh we
love it no
[Music]
[Music]
where's your ass bro
[ __ ]
this way
[Music]
Daniel what what's going on hey Chris
okay
yeah no we have to leave right now
I knew you won't stay sorry uh
wish we could you better come back hold
on a second here this is your cape
you're the real superhero Danes dress
that's super cool like you Daniel let's
go take the troll forest shortcut it's
right through there
nobody will find you Chris
you rock
goodbye captain spirit
see you around super wolf the spirit
squad will stay united forever
whoa
[Music]
new last Mon it's too good to be true
I feel a date a fait superhero Chris was
so sad when he found out that he had to
find out anyway before he did something
dangerous dangerous I know I just feel
sorry for him
don't be no matter what happened I think
you guys will always be friends
I hope so much I'm tired of running away
I don't want to be a superhero anymore
you don't have to use your power if you
don't want to
I know but sometimes I can help
and I've learned no one to use it you
don't you can only trust your cuts and
listen to your brother then we'll see
grant want grandpa again I don't know
we'll see
well here we done it go now mom no way
men okay we don't eat her okay but you
said you wanted to find us we stick to
the plan we go to what Apple logos
that's where we belong
no one will tell us what to do we can be
whoever we want you think their mom had
these powers that well and that's why
she left because she was worried that
her mom wouldn't understand because she
was so religious I even got you a
present
what if her dad even kind of neighbors
when he found out about Daniel he got
freaked out but it's in two weeks
who cares dates are boring here yeah
present
it's weird sorry I like it
yeah I reckon that's definitely it their
mum had the power to Chris why she's
worried about she kind of hey I guess
she kind of knows what's happening I got
something for you too I wanted to finish
it but we're doing it now so
and so cool
[Music]
Hey
listen there's her right come on all
aboard
hey we're gonna meet up with Cassidy
again are we I think we are
[Music]
the end of this episode
I think the next one comes up pretty
soon actually
[Music]
[Music]
leave
okay let's look at our choices we
through this noble properly and most
people through at Daniel I don't want to
hurt and you intervened and scared the
Cougar off fifty eight percent bit so
most people did that I prayed together
most people did that quite a lot people
do that you pretend you didn't know
anything most people did that but just
5050
I help with the chores yeah smooth who
did that we're all good people at heart
um told Daniel he did the right thing
when he said Chris most people did that
yeah cuz till it was like he's he saved
someone I didn't use Stevens laptop no I
was I was a good boy it was a good boy I
didn't use the phone to call Lila I
didn't even know that was an option most
people did that too I didn't gain
Chris's trust was I supposed to Oh
by getting all the toys in the right Oh
damnit most people didn't get that right
I guess that's cuz you just
instinctively think it's 3v3
so that they'll be like three good three
bad but it's actually forged too bad
that's what got me all hmm tow done to
stop lying to Chris Oh most people said
to protect the secret I wonder if
anything does happen to Crescent if you
didn't turn the truth I listened to
Cassidy Solent at the end it was
wouldn't do that um you didn't draw for
Chris damn it I didn't know that I could
talk I was wrong hmm you brought a
Christmas present for Daniel yes I did
and those people did that so you could
have stole her as well but me didn't get
involved in Charles Charles's problems
people didn't do that you let Daniel use
I tried to I thought was asking you a
question but he kind of turned out
judgey you got Daniels's power as most
people did that yeah and the [ __ ] didn't
chase you and Chris helped you escape oh
my god Chris get Oh 43% of people had an
ending where Chris got hit by a car I
guess that's probably if you lied to him
and made him think he had powers the
cops chased you and Chris wasn't hit by
a car how would the cops have chased us
do you reckon don't know but we seem to
get the best ending I'm pretty happy
with that don't continue to swear damn
it I didn't stop me
Daniel when the dice game without
cheating yes he did Dan you didn't get
killed a cougar good Daniel was not able
to pay mushroom I know I know but I'd
rather him do that then yeah kill
something don't agree to pray Daniel
wasn't asked to help with the chores
yeah cuz I didn't find him stupidly
Daniel Baden Tok rested the truth was
power that's good overall Daniel was
repressed
Danny was holed CEO truth but he
continued lying oh my gosh that was a
choice
overall Daniel was repressed losing his
power don't know didn't you have to save
Chris no we didn't then use this power
to save Chris in the car oh damn
I wonder why or how I'm gonna have to
watch some more playthroughs of this
this is why people watch this game after
playing it because there's so many
different outcomes
Daniel enjoyed his only Christmas
present yeah cool okay well that is the
end I think the next episode is coming
soon because I played that one seriously
late Oh these little n-bit let's watch
this together
so this is it yeah
it looks like a nettle field and it
stinks wait yeah this mouse they don't
come on I'll show you around
it's for Cassidy and this is a job I
guess it's a nice green maintenance okay
cool say yeah I reckon their mum has the
powers too
that's why she's looking out for the
kids from afar and that's what she sent
the letter I reckon that's also why she
ran away maybe she was scared of her own
powers wanted to protect other people so
I reckon that's what's happening here
but we shall find out in the next
episode which should be coming out soon
anyway
do let me know if you enjoyed this or
not and if not what kind of games true
wants to be play because I know you guys
love anything Resident Evil and I'm
always up playing more horror games but
I don't know if you know please do but
as always follow me on Twitter
YAG Man X to find out what I'm streaming
next and you can also join the discord
should be in the description below but
I'm gonna say goodbye to who I can see
in the chat now anyway so thank you so
much for joining me thanks to Joe Quinn
thanks to Nikki thanks to Albert whoo
thanks to evil and I am from originally
from Plymouth it's like down by Cornwall
in England by Ross well bye who else can
I see Tom if you're still here bye
officer Naruto by Dustin if it's oh you
left a while ago
okay good bye and bye as well to anyone
who might be lurking and not in the chat
that's perfectly fine but I see you I
already I don't know
but I see a number I know you're there
so thank you very much for watching I
hope you enjoyed and I will see you in
the next video or live stream whenever
that will be okay Jerry